on va voir une scène alors vous allez
chez le pdg la non mais vous ne lancez
pas le film de suite vous allez chez le
pdg qui est joué par patrick chesnais et
vous lui lisais l'amant de marides duras
dans un premier temps il s'endort et
puis ils se réveillent de nouveau et on
va donc voir la scène maintenant la
deuxième scène où vous avez une
altercation de là tous les deux voici
miu miu patrick chesnais je suis votre
lectrice je n'ai plus du tout le même je
voulais bien d'autres choses je n'ai pas
l'intention d'arrêter la règle sachez le
bon alors julie s'ils ne sont pas des
chaussures qui font ce qu'il y à
d'insolites d'inouï ce jour là dans la
tenue de la petite ce qu'il y à ce jour
là c'est que la petite porte sur la tête
un chapeau d'homme bord plat un feutre
souple ou leur voix de rose aux larges
rubans noirs s'est réveillé ce ne sont
pas les chaussures qui font sûrement la
première fois de leurs 15 ans et demi
c'est la traversée du fleuve veux je
porte une robe de soie naturelle elle
est usée presque transparente et voilà
voilà où j'en suis une fois ce comme
celle là me tue ses trois buts j'ai
presque toi parents ponctuent vous me
tuer je sens un frisson que tu veux pas
pouvoir des accusations plaisir qui nous
submerge
c'est beau c'est très beau vous écouter
vous êtes débloquer ce que madame poêlé
ou non j'ai pas fait l'amour depuis six
mois à eau